>> Greg: IF YOU'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO SANTANA, YOU WON'T
LIKE FAUCI'S LATEST RANT-A.
IF YOU CAN'T FIND THE GRINCH, IT
WILL DO IN A PINCH.
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI IS ALREADY
TRYING TO CANCEL CHRISTMAS
APPEARING ON "FACE THE NATION,"
HE LET HIS INNER SCROOGE OUT.
>> BUT WE CAN GATHER FOR
CHRISTMAS OR IT'S JUST SUIT
GNOMIC TOO SOON TO TELL?
>> IT'S JUST TOO SOON TO TELL,
WE GOT TO CONCENTRATE ON
CONTINUING TO GET THOSE NUMBERS
DOWN AND NOT TRY TO JUMP AHEAD
BY WEEKS OR MONTHS AND SAY WHAT
WE ARE GOING TO DO IT A
PARTICULAR TIME.
>> Greg: AND MAKE SURE YOUR
TREE IS WEARING A MASK.
FAUCI ALREADY WALKED BACK HIS
COMMENTS SAYING THEY WERE
MISINTERPRETED, BUT IF YOU DO
GATHER FOR THE HOLIDAYS, CDC
RECOMMEND SKIPPING 6 FEET APART
FROM OTHERS AND USE WINDOW FANS
AND OPEN WINDOWS TO CIRCULATE
FRESH AIR.
OPEN WINDOWS IN THE WINTER, THAT
WILL GO GREAT IN CHICAGO.
YOU WILL EITHER DIAL FROM --
DIED FROM PNEUMONIA OR A HAIL OF
BULLETS.
BUT THE PANDEMIC MIGHT ACTUALLY
HELP YOU SAVE A FEW BUCKS.
IF YOU'RE AN INTOLERANT CHEAP A
HOLE, A NEW SURVEY BY COIN STAR
FOUND ONE IN EIGHT AMERICANS
WOULD NOT GIVE A GIFT TO A
FAMILY MEMBER OR FRIEND WHO DID
NOT SHARE THEIR SAME COVID
VIEWS.
IF THE GOOD NEWS, IF YOU'RE
FILLING OUT A SURVEY AT COIN
STAR, YOU'RE TOO BROKE TO BUY
ANYTHING GOOD.
BUT WE NEED TO REMIND OURSELVES
HOW MUCH OF THIS IS THEATER AND
VIRTUE SIGNALING.
A VIDEO OF A DOJ OFFICIAL
RECIRCULATED ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
SHOWING HIM ASKING UP WHEN HE
THOUGHT NO ONE WAS LOOKING AND
THEN ONLY TO REMOVE IT JUST
SECONDS LATER.
WORE IT APPROXIMATELY TWO
SECONDS, THAT GUY, AND THIS IS
HAPPENING ALL OVER THE PLACE.
I WAS HOPING THAT THIS WOULD GET
BETTER, BUT IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S
GETTING WORSE.
>> HOW WAS THE WEEKEND?
>> GOOD, AND YOU?
>> I'M ABOUT TO WATCH SQUID
GAME.
>> HOW IS LIFE?
>> I DON'T TO TALK ABUT IT.
>> LET'S GO RIGHT NOW.
>> SOUNDS GOOD.
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: TYRUS, IT'S AS GOOD A
TIME AS ANY TO TELL ME, WHAT ARE
YOU GETTING ME FOR CHRISTMAS?
>> THE SAME THING YOU GOT ME,
AND AUTOGRAPHED PICTURE OF YOU.
>> Greg: REGIFTING.
>> YES, IT'S THE NEW THING.
YOU KNOW, AS I SAT WATCHING THE
TAMPA BAY-PATRIOTS GAME LAST
NIGHT AND HEARD THE CROWD
CHANTING "BRADY, BRADY," I
LOOKED TO SEE THAT FAUCI SAID
REMIND PEOPLE TO GET TOGETHER
FOR CHRISTMAS.
WHERE HAVE YOU BEEN, BRO?
WE'VE MOVED ON WITHOUT YOU.
LIKE, NO ONE --
WE KNOW THERE ARE SHARKS IN THE
WATER.
WE WILL LOOK FOR THE SIGNS, BUT
NEW YEAR'S EVE PARTY AT THE
CRIB, EVERYBODY.
I MEAN...
WE'VE MOVED ON.
>> Greg: DOES THAT INCLUDE ME?
AM I INVITED?
>> YES, YOU'VE GOT TO WORK THE
DOOR.
>> Greg: LESS TO ME AT YOUR
PARTY, YOU USED ME IN THE DWARF
TOSS, IT WASN'T FUN.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT I SIGNED.
>> YOU HAD TO MISS WORK FOR
THAT.
>> Greg: IT WAS A TOUGH ONE.
CONGRESS HIM, DO WE NEED IS
PERMISSION?
HE'S NOT A LEADER COMING AS A
BUREAUCRAT, SO HE'S NEVER EVER
GOING TO SAY SOMETHING THAT IS
LEADER-LIKE, HE'S ALWAYS GOING
TO HEDGE HIS BETS, THAT'S WHAT
HE DOES.
>> HE WANTS TO BE ALL UP IN
EVERYBODY'S BUSINESS.
IF YOU WOULD HAVE HIS WAY, HE
WOULD HAVE EVERYBODY REPLACING
THEIR ELF ON A SHELF WITH
EVERYWHERE THERE WOULD BE, YOU
KNOW, FAUCI ON THE COUCHE.
OF IT WOULD BE EVERYWHERE
NOW THEY WANT WINDOW FANS.
WE ARE HERE IN NEW YORK RIGHT
NOW.
YOU IMAGINE AT THE CDC MEETING,
THEY MUST HAVE HAD A HOSE
CONNECTED TO A CAR MUFFLER WITH
EXHAUST FUMES FILLING UP THAT
ROOM.
SO I ACTUALLY DO FEEL BAD FOR
THE PEOPLE WHO SAY THEY WON'T
GIVE TO SOMEBODY ELSE.
THEY LISTEN TO FAUCI, THEY ARE
READING THE CDC GUIDANCE.
IN THERE LIKE THEY ARE SO
TRIGGERED BY IT SO I'M NOT EVEN
GOING TO BE GIVING GIFTS MY
LOVED ONE'S.
I MUST FEEL BAD, YOU HAVE TO
IMAGINE THE PEOPLE AREN'T GIVING
THEM GIFTS BECAUSE THEY ARE SUCH
A MISERABLE HUMAN BEING.
>> Greg: WRITES, THAT'S TRUE.
IF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE SAYING
THAT, DAGEN, YOU PROBABLY DON'T
WANT THEM AT YOUR CHRISTMAS
CELEBRATION OR GATHERING.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU CELEBRATE
CHRISTMAS.
>> OF COURSE I DO.
ALWAYS NEED SOMEBODY OF THE
TABLE YOU WOULDN'T BE UPSET IF
THEY GOT STABBED WITH A STEAK
KNIFE ON THE BACK OF THE HAND.
>> Greg: YEAH.
>> MY FAMILY WILL GET THAT JOKE.
[AWKWARD LAUGHTER]
I REALLY QUICKLY MIGHT HAVE TO
EDIT THIS, BUT I THOUGHT --
>> Greg: I LIKE IT, GIVING US
A TRIGGER WARNING.
YOU MIGHT HAVE TO EDIT THIS.
>> I THINK ABOUT WHY DO THEY
KEEP THIS GUY AROUND AND IT'S
THE OLD [BLEEP] THEORY.
IF YOU ARE AN OLD [BLEEP], YOU
WANT AN OLDER [BLEEP] AROUND YOU
SO YOU LOOK BETTER BY
COMPARISON, SO IF YOU'RE A BOOZY
TROLLOP, THEN YOU WANT A BOOZIER
MORE TROLLOPY PERSON AROUND
BECAUSE YOU LOOK BETTER.
KAT UNDERSTANDS.
>> I GET IT.
>> WHY YOU HANG OUT WITH KILL
ME?
>> HE IS QUITE THE BOOZY
TROLLOP.
THAT'S THE NAME OF HIS YACHT, BY
THE WAY, THE BOOZY TROLLOP.
THINGS WE DO OUT IN
INTERNATIONAL WATERS, YOU DON'T
WANT TO KNOW, RIGHT, KAT?
I SHOWED YOU THOSE PICTURES
ONCE.
THAT WAS AN IGUANA.
>> YEAH.
YEAH, INDEED IT WAS, GREG.
YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT THAT?
>> Greg: NO!
NO, NO, NO!
WHAT IS YOUR -- WHATEVER.
LOOK, MAN, IT'S MONDAY, GIVE ME
A BREAK.
>> IT IS MONDAY.
IT'S THE MOST MONDAY -- IT'S
MONDAY EVERY TIME THIS GUY
TALKS.
I CAN'T HAVE ANY REACTION TO
ANYTHING HE SAYS ANYMORE EXCEPT
FOR JUST "K."
ALL RIGHT, BUDDY, I'M GOING TO
DO ME, ARE NOT GOING LISTEN TO
YOU.
>> Greg: IF YOU DON'T
UNDERSTAND GETTING RISK DOWN TO
ZERO IS IMPOSSIBLE, THEN YOU'RE
NOT A LEADER.
EVERYTHING WE DO ENTAILS RISK.
DRIVING CARS.
>> ESPECIALLY THE MOST FUN
STUFF.
>> Greg: EXACTLY!
>> WE NEED TO CHECK WHAT
DEMOCRATS HUSBAND JUST BOUGHT
STOCK IN WINDOW FANS.
>> I'M GOING T